[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's right it's Northey on the track
six year old made her debut performing
on the runway at her dad's fashion show
the Cutie did her thing and took her job
seriously as the models rocked the Yeezy
season 8 collection Norris made it clear
in her lyrics that she will never do bad
things and she likes to do the whoa with
her chips kanye was in full support mode
for his baby girl towards the end of
North's performance the rapper made his
way onto the runway to stand by her side
[Music]
norik also managed to throw on a
shout-out to her cousin P before leaving
the runway with the bang or should I say
another screamer too
[Music]
[Applause]
at the North's big performance she
celebrated with mom and dad a week
before she hit the runway she warmed up
by performing another original song for
her first-grade classmate
[Music]
once again Kanye right there by her side
the six-year-old definitely has the
performer Jean Norris is never shy
showing off her dance moves at her dad's
Sunday service when it comes to if the
cutie will follow in Kanye's musical
footsteps it might be too early the
judge her mom Kim Kardashian tells et Oh
pressure I hope that they just find
their own motivation and no matter what
that is no matter what they want to do
in life I hope that they work really
hard I think they have good exam I
learned from seeing both of my parents
work really hard and I think our kids
will see you know Kanye and I work
really hard and I hope that's motivating
for them and just to find their own path
they think to not pressure but to
definitely have our rules is the best
that you can do
[Music]